a students that he assaulted at an elite
New Hampshire prep school is an illegal
bowel this morning to keep her identity
private Owen LaBrie was convicted in the
case that drew national attention the
victim's family follows civil suit in
June against st. Paul school the family
claims the school condoned quote a
tradition of ritualized statutory rape
now the school denies this allegation
and says if the case goes to trial the
plaintiffs quote should not be allowed
to hide behind a cloak of anonymity and
lob attacks but it also tells CBS News
in a statement that while it has no
desire or intention to reveal the
identity of the young woman it will work
to ensure this case is fairly considered
in court proceedings and not through
media attacks CBS News legal analyst
reclaimer joins us at the table to
discuss Ricky good morning good morning
so Owen LaBrie was convicted in the
criminal case but the civil case is
different what is the family alleging
that the school is doing it do they have
a case yes they have a case and what the
family is saying is that the school not
only condoned a culture where minor
women could be sexually assaulted by
older men because it was the senior
salute that is a senior boy who would go
after a freshman girl in order to score
whatever that meant and that it was
institutionalized and as a result the
plaintiff says look they breached a duty
of care they're negligent they inflicted
emotional distress they had premises
that were unsafe all of these are
recognized ways to go to court and sue
an entity so should the victim be
identified well that of course is the
ultimate question we have to look
Charlie at what this motion really says
as opposed to how it may have been
reported in the news the motion is
looking for three things the motion is
looking for a gag order and that's
really what these defense lawyers are
really mad about what they say is they
were sabotage that what happened was the
plaintiffs lawyers filed a complaint
they had not even gotten a copy of it
the plaintiffs lawyers went on a media
barrage and that what they want is to
get the plaintiffs lawyers to stop
talking
well if they had just filed that motion
it probably would have been successful
unfortunately for the defense they
combined it with this idea of saying
look we'll let you go under a pseudonym
that's okay you can be Jane and John Doe
parents of JD but in exchange our little
quid pro quo is you've got to stop
talking and that that's really not how
this should be done they want to have
her name open in two ways number one
discovery how do we get medical records
of girl who says that she's
psychologically distressed emotionally
distressed if we have to serve a
subpoena that says JD we need her name
well that's reasonable that doesn't
become public but when they go and say
at trial which could be years from now
because we want our yeah she's still a
minor for a couple of more months yeah
but by the time it goes to trial she
won't be a minor does that matter at all
her I think it does matter I think that
we always protect minors across the
country we never let out their names in
litigation or juvenile courts in
criminal proceedings but what we do here
is we find out at the time she's an
adult at times of trial there have been
cases that have said the pseudonym the
Jane Doe has got to go is this precedent
setting it could be precedent-setting
even though these cases have been done
many times before this is not a new
thing the reason it could be
precedent-setting here and cause a
terrible chilling effect on women who
would like to come forward who are under
age or who have simply been sexual
assault victims is that this case is so
infamous the entire press corps that
went there was not only national was
international so we don't want women to
feel young or old that they could not go
forward in a civil case because their
names will be made public however they
could have dealt with the thought of
making her name public at trial a year
or two years from now the fact that
they've done it now when there is school
and a school is supposed to be a place
that nurtures their students that that's
really why they have endured so much bad
bad publicity here
do you see this backfiring more on the
school well I think it's backfiring
enough now I think that they made a
calculated choice but this calculation
may have been an error thank you thank
you